foreign
well just let me know when your guests
start pouring in
hello Jalen
yeah I was a bit late with my stream
OBS was like you have to you have to set
a broadcast or something like oh I don't
remember ever to do that ever
uh they're the the people are pouring in
so this is a little collaboration with
uh Nintendo black crisis everyone
hello I'm Nintendo black crisis
I'm sure that my most of my audience
knows you because all of my best videos
feature you
I'm sensing a pattern here
yeah
well you're finally gonna do a ikana
video right or oh no wait maybe you were
not sure yet I'm not sure yet I'm on the
dungeon Theory uh you know
path so I might if I did like uh a Stone
Tower Temple I'd probably fit the kind
of stuff in there anyways uh hello uh G
JD Lord Dan Roland uh
uh Karma clutch Poncho Fireblade DJ
Thunder
Sarah kamitsu lepi PSI squishy woozy La
Fortney
with that milk uh
it's like I gotta I gotta like just you
know just in case I have to like quickly
screen the names it's like all right I'm
not there's no offensive things here
it's like hello n-word it's like oh oh
God
it was yeah we got plenty of people here
uh we're all super excited I'm sure for
this direct I mean at this point I think
most of us are expecting more news
I mean if the game's coming out like May
12th I think then
we gotta get something oh yeah well it
did say uh games uh releasing in the
first half of this year which includes
two of the Kingdom so imagine imagine if
they like set the release date before
that to like one day after that
the first half this is a this is a to
troll us
oh there
oh it's
after doesn't count no
no they pretty much locked it in with
that last tweet where they're like
Nintendo of Europe and all the other
accounts were like
they were the first ones to post it
right Nintendo Europe
yeah it's gonna be hilarious if like
they posted that and not realizing that
it was delayed and then everyone else
was like well we got it we gotta just
roll with it
now Nintendo is a pretty well oiled
machine in that in that regard like
usually whatever they post is
coordinated with the other branches
so I'm pretty sure that's uh
that's gonna work
besides they gave us the release date
not too long ago if they really were too
still unsure they wouldn't have given us
a specific date
I think by by this point it's pretty
much locked in now
but uh yeah so uh we wanted to do uh
tears of the Kingdom Bingo but we just
had it card that said zonai all out like
over and over again
for the record uh it was his idea not
mine
you know like if I didn't say that
people are like oh that was definitely
NBC's idea
[Laughter]
well to be honest though let's just open
it up uh Stronger with this one do you
expect anything Zona in this trailer
but before I say that uh both uh on both
our streams you should really look at
the description there's some important
news there just
just wanted to bring that up oh yeah
anyways
sorry what was the question again like
like in in all seriousness do you expect
to see anything zonai related in this
trailer
or if we get a trailer of course but
if we will if we will get a well to
start I assume that this Trail over and
I get because people a big topic has
been you know how much story would they
show I feel like the trailer the next
trailer we get it's gonna be a
structured exactly like they did with
the
um 2017 trailer for breath of the wild I
think it'll just be that same structure
where you know it's bits of voice lines
and stuff some story cut scenes out of
context oh boy
I and that's kind of what I'm hoping I
don't a big topic recently has been how
people feel like
they need to do more advertising for
tears of the kingdom and stuff like that
I agree um and they definitely uh do
some people assume though that when
people are saying that that you know
it's
Story related but
they can advertise a bunch and still
only gives a give us bits of story and
that's what I'm hoping for and I think a
lot of people are hoping for because you
don't want to this is something like
this a release such as this doesn't
happen you know every year so yeah a lot
of us want to go in not knowing much so
we you know get surprised as we play now
so on that topic
I don't think they really would have
anything
sonai related assuming that there was
some zonai stuff in the final game maybe
like some more like a statue structure
that we see yeah yeah or like the
background the one weapon link had it
was the flamethrower that had the sonai
dragon head so maybe like little bits of
that but
Story related I don't think so
yeah oh yeah I agree uh Bethany uh I
also want voice acting in this trailer
if there's one thing that was a bit
weird and underwhelming about the past
few teasers is that it's all quiet it
feels not very personal
so
can you imagine if we hear Ganondorf
speak
that would be amazing
yeah I'm gonna make one like prediction
that's like it's never gonna happen and
it's probably completely untrue but it's
just gonna be one of those predictions
where it's like it's ridiculous
but I'm still I still hope it it it
shows up I really hope there's something
vati related in tears of the Kingdom
well yeah just a lot of past villains
it'd be cool if any of them
somehow
you know
yeah but I mean who knows it like vati
specifically they like to bring in a
bunch of stuff and then not really
bring it back
but can you imagine if if uh bati and
Ganondorf would be to together as the
main antagonist in the in this game that
would be freaking crazy I'm just or if
or if this game tries to pull off like a
Multiverse thing oh uh you know kind of
like the Hyrule Warriors and stuff
yeah as long as it doesn't have time
travel
yeah time travel is
like if they've done a lot if they're
gonna do time travel just do it like
this time shift stones or something but
I don't want them to go back to like oh
let's go back in time and save Zelda
it's like no that's too easy
that's one thing I really want though
you mentioned the time shift zones
that's something I I really want to see
come back yeah because it's such a fun
mechanic not only like uh well mostly
gameplay wise but I could have some bits
of story to it hmm
foreign
it's too good of a mechanic not to
include again in a future title
oh hey Dwayne
thank you for joining
much appreciated
oh we got high Knox music and on my end
what what a what is playing in your uh
in your background
some relaxing Shrine music uh much
better
on the topic of that actually one thing
that I always use in my videos I don't
know about you but I love the blessing
and Shrine theme
it's so like Serene yeah I always I
always have to use that yeah it's great
I don't know if I don't know what piece
to use that's usually the number one or
Link's Awakening face Shrine I always
use that in my videos it's so good it's
such a good track yeah especially
amazing especially if you compare it to
the original
where it's like it's not at all like
that it's just bleeps and bloops
yeah
but uh yeah there's always that that I I
often use
lorellen Village or uh Gerudo Town night
time version
uh when I do them more like analytical
videos I always want the the more
relaxing themes I usually go with that
one
yeah the gruno town night one is really
peaceful yeah
most of the nighttime versions are much
better to have in the background because
they're a little less
energetic so it doesn't overshadow your
voice your voice over
that's why I absolutely love the main
theme of breath of the wild but that
volume changes drastically throughout
the whole piece yes whenever I use it
like it's one of those soundtracks where
whenever I use it in a video I have to
get to a certain point and then I have
to cut it
and then with the next section I gotta
like lower it to try and match the
previous bit and then I just gotta like
fade it so it hopefully sounds okay I
usually just ramp it down as it starts
to get near that volume Spike
and it just goes like slowly down slowly
down and then it goes like and I have to
do that like at least four times because
that that that song just keeps ramping
up and up and up
yeah for good reason but you know it
videos uh thank you Nats for joining
that's awesome welcome shiny duck fish
for the five dollar donation appreciate
it look at that getting done getting
that money
yeah
I think you're just gaming you are also
amazing
we just keep trying to one-up each other
oh thank you for the fifteen dollars 100
is so much man
and then at the end we go is that Mr
Beast in the chat
that would be pretty nuts
I think imagine that actually being like
a challenge someone did where like two
people went live and they try to like
one-up each other
and then people just like started
donating
it's like oh well we got money I guess
Mr Divine bees oh thank you the art of
mean
oh is it mean because you just uh joined
as a new uh member
I saw oh oh oh good job oh I'm a shiny
duck fish five dollars thank you very
much
that is awesome
thank you for your generosity
you're over there like wow five dollars
on my side and a new channel member my
goodness
[Laughter]
I'm actually gonna add you to the
credits of the next video uh art of mean
but I don't know if it's mean or men or
mene or something like that uh do you
and monster maze do this for for a
full-time uh living shop yep I do it and
I know like monster maze he has because
he previously like you worked in like
animations and stuff right so you have
yes is it like kind of like freelance I
assume what you do uh oh one sec a
random citizen thank you so much he says
challenge accepted who wants to go
against me and he gave me twenty dollars
oh Anthony Anthony Young thank you so
much for joining that's awesome
welcome uh but yeah I I used to be a
freelance animator uh before that I was
a software developer which was the more
boring years of my life did that for
about eight years and then I started
my own animation one-man company I guess
you could call it
but I'm doing it full time now too uh
YouTube I've
as I started focusing more on the
channel
I did less and less of animating in the
background for corporate stuff because
obviously doing YouTube is much more fun
being able to animate Zelda stuff is a
lot more fun than animating like uh
a meeting or something
so yeah I think I've been
able to do this full-time for about a
year now before that I did have to fill
it up with animation jobs too
or else I wouldn't I wouldn't be able to
make ends meet
hi uh
e emerge thank you so much
uh John asks do you think do you think
the trailer that we're gonna get today
is going to give us more information on
the creature or do you think that
Nintendo will wait for us to find it in
game I I assume they would wait and not
really show much about that
uh like the the one on the mural the
that bizarre looking the the
highly a creature uh what yeah those
people no one's surrounded by the tears
oh we got more donations incoming uh
Anthony Young
thank you so much we gotta beat NBC he
gave me 20 22 and 30. yeah I'd say
you're winning Dwayne
25 I accept your challenge thank you so
much guys it's really awesome this is
like that Meme where it's like stop he's
already dead
uh I'm I'm sure there's gonna be loads
of people uh donating to you
no but seriously thank you guys so much
to the generosity is it's uh
heartwarming really
especially since we're all here for the
same goal most of us at least to
celebrate Zelda and to see what's gonna
happen
open-air dungeons ooh
uh but uh yeah the hylia creature thingy
uh which I I'm still not sure if that's
actually highly what do you think it is
what is your like running Theory right
now on that creature
um do you think it's something new or
something we know
something new I do think it's supposed
to be like a depiction of hylia
if it's if it's something entirely
different I I guess it might be like a
zonai related deity
I don't know
much else uh about what it could we'd be
honest one second my doorbell is ringing
can you keep my audience occupied for a
sec I'll be right back yeah no problem
yeah no problem
foreign
let's just hope he doesn't re-watch this
part of this stream where I had no trash
talking no I'm joking uh thank you so
much the art of meme the art of mean I
did it as well with monster maze for the
five dollars the double agent
uh I appreciate it
I think the green hand is the bean and
the carving who is another princess like
we've seen before oh like midna or Hilda
that would be an interesting take
it was just a package
a late late night package
now now your chat's uh sending you uh
stuff
oh
wow that delivery that delivery is fast
um
yeah it would be interesting if the
green hand was related to like a new
character such as midna or Hilda one
thing that I didn't see talked about
very often with like when the very first
trailer came out is a possibility that
this hand could also like serve the role
as a companion character of sorts so I
mean it's always possible that could
happen but I would love to see a new
character who accompanies you like midna
or Hilda I I replayed Twilight Princess
for like the second time
ever recently and midnight was such a
good character
yeah she was Anthony Young thank you so
much for the 20 donation awesome let's
try let's try and give it up with
monster maze
I appreciate it thank you very much uh
no quintessentials it was delivered by
Van I thought someone slammed into our
house but they were just parked very
weirdly
is coming to the switch yes thank you
why is that not a thing yet like it has
to happen right we have to get Wind
Waker and and Twilight Princess to the
switch I don't know why it hasn't
happened yet but it's something that
there's no way it's not gonna happen it
should be the easiest Port ever that is
a good topic though of like maybe to
what we are gonna expect from the this
direct aside from tears of the Kingdom
stuff by the way Poncho thank you for
the five dollar donation uh here's a
question what got you guys into Zelda
for me it's funny when I grew up I
wasn't actually a huge Zelda uh fan I
was mostly into like Mario and stuff
like that hmm I don't know really what
got me into Zelda it was just another
one of those really big Nintendo related
games I my first Zelda was Majora's Mask
terrible
first game to try and get into the
series I know for some people you know
it could be seen it still is a good one
but the fact that it's a time limit just
kind of pressures you um thank you so
much for the uh I don't know how much
that is uh in uh US dollars but thank
you so much for the
200 knock and okay what is that oh and
thank you for uh joining uh banoon I saw
your Twitter message I will respond
after this whole storm passes
uh and okay what is that again I know
that yeah I can't remember uh so I'm
sure someone who doesn't understand
Curry and she's like whoa two hundred
dollars
so so uh back to the topic uh
expectations for the direct aside from
tears of the Kingdom news
some of the things I'm hoping for is
obviously Twilight Princess and
moonmaker ports to the switch
um I also
I wouldn't be surprised if they released
a tears of the Kingdom themed switch
console because I definitely get that
right yeah well I don't know well
disregarding the leak before that I was
always thinking that they probably I'd
be surprised if they didn't
um have one so I hope that uh is a thing
uh Golem thank you so so much for the
two dollars
um and then my other two hopes were
uh
uh big 3D Mario game it's been long
enough I want to see the next big 3D
Mario game and then my most unrealistic
expectation
but one that I would love to see is a
remaster of Paper Mario Thousand your
door for the switch favorite game of all
time that's my favorite game of all time
yeah it's one of my favorites too I
remember a super old article and it like
it mentioned that like Nintendo was
thinking about it based on if people
wanted it but I'm not sure how like
valid that was but I just
I that that would sell it for me even
like you know
even if we oh um included tears of the
Kingdom there you were sharing your uh
your backstory about how you got into
Zelda right uh give me one sec uh sah
Gollum thank you so much for the two
dollars
um oh we have some questions also uh
Dave Dave S thank you so much is it me
or does the hylia creature bear Striker
resemblance to the creature that is
attacking Ganondorf in the E3 2019
trailer in the flashback
yeah
that shadow on the wall you mean right
do you remember that uh NBC or will yeah
yeah the The Flash and the shadow and
you see the big hand the that creature
on the mural does have like
abnormally long arms and pretty big
hands like if you compared him to the
Zelda depiction where they're like
locking hands like that that other
creature is clearly a lot taller and
bigger
well it's kind of bizarre because I I
remember looking into like to see if the
the figure also had the very like sharp
nails and in a lot of like angles and
parts of the fingers it looks like it's
completely normal zeldas but there's one
specific uh finger I think it might be
might have been the thumb that it's
quite obviously supposed to have like a
sharp nail at the end but it's weird
because that's the only instance where
it's a thing which has always been kind
of weird to me but yeah it it could also
be related to the
um the hand holding down Ganondorf yeah
because that was one of the initial
thoughts for I think so first trailer
that was one of the initial uh thoughts
that a lot of us had where it might have
been related to the hand that was you
know reached out for gandorf especially
since you know it's sealing him at the
moment and what we see might be what
happened prior to it like with the yeah
and with the most recent trailer
I I could definitely see the figure
being related to that hand somehow thank
you so much Carly Dobson for the 20
donation Zelda Zelda Zelda Zelda yeah
I'm so excited yeah hope you're doing
good
uh we got another question from uh taker
610 uh thank you for the five dollars
Twilight Princess to me is like the
ultimate expression of the Zelda formula
breath of the wild more than tripled its
sales pretty amazing the pressure is on
for tears of the Kingdom oh yeah for
sure uh what what do you think what is
your stance on Twilight Princess because
you recently played it it's for
connections the connections no no just
in general like what is your opinion of
like is it uh like what what is your
general opinion about Twila princess
since it's fresh in your memory right
now you just played it
I am really happy that I finally went
back to replay it because when I said it
was the second time I mean like I had
only ever played it once before and that
was the very first time obviously
because you know played it once and it
was back on the the Wii version
and I'm just really happy I got to play
the HD because I I had a lot of fun with
it
um yeah
it it is a bit of a slow start but it
isn't as
bad as I remember I guess
well
maybe because you know what to do but
like when I played this for the first
time you are running around the The
Village quite a lot like what am I what
am I doing right yeah that's true yeah
but you know it's
a lot of the dungeons are just really
fun in Twilight Princess they're so good
like snow peak ruins
yeah the Temple of Time like it has so
many amazing dungeons it has so many
good dungeons it's crazy
yeah it's uh it's literally Ocarina of
Time on steroids and like I said mineral
is like the best companion character
yeah
it feels like she's like
she's not even a companion she's more
than a companion it's I actually her
story mostly she's the Twilight Princess
yeah but I think the reason why it's so
good is because when you think about it
a lot of the other characters they just
don't go through like their own
character Arc there's no development
hey good blood is here
and midna has oh hey hello good blood
hope you're doing good you know the uh
you know the documentary he made right
yeah yeah that big one um the Zelda
subtex what was it what was that called
the thumbnail Master Class Master Class
master class and subjects yeah master
class and video editing yeah
uh yeah pretty much so good when I saw
that video I was like well
I like I still have a lot this is one of
the best this is one of the best Zelda
videos I still have a long way to go
with my editing uh and animation stuff
thank you so much Larry Lightfoot for
the final AutoNation I wanted a GameCube
digital in the line of the NES SNES N64
and Genesis they have oh yeah you mean
like the Nintendo switch online virtual
console yeah I they it's so frustrating
that they haven't because if they're
gonna charge for that they really and if
also more importantly if they're gonna
be so upset about like piracy but also
not make these games available
hmm you think they would have it on the
as Virtual Console or something
yeah yeah yeah
it's it's uh what what by the way what
do you think of that uh price increase
that we saw which may or may not be true
because it they did remove it
but they it's like tears the Kingdom
right 70 bucks yeah well like the thing
is yeah I think it's if that actually
happened I I think it would be
ridiculous but obviously I'd still buy
it because you know it's my job
um
and I think a lot of people who would be
upset about it they would still buy it
yeah no it's still it's still Zelda and
it's inflation but okay but but here's
the thing all right
in in Canada okay
um
a game a Nintendo switch game currently
is
79.99
wait really yep yep
huh that's that's our current price so
if it went up again
hmm
oh dear yeah yeah inflation man it's uh
it's not fun
uh yeah well there's also there's also
just a difference in currency you know
US Dollar Canadian dollar yeah true true
because here it's uh usually 60 Euros
but the euro is worth less than a dollar
I if I remember correctly make you laugh
ortony for the 999
999 donation do you think that the large
figures we see with Zelda hylia is this
on his iteration of Majora and they are
forming some peace packed I don't think
it it's related to Majora and also
Majora is
um
Majora's
straight up evil you know I I don't know
if that would be connected to him at all
plus it kind of feels like Majora was
always kind of if it's its own confined
story and after that it's just
done basically I know I made a whole
video called the the return of Majora
but that was more like a hypothetical
like technically the evil should still
be inside the mask if the if it came
from one of the other two timelines but
it's
yeah I mean I don't actually expect that
to
to show up again yeah like it's
important to not to not try and not
always have to look with a super super
critical I and it's fun just just to
talk about what could be
yeah and Nintendo's also very
unpredictable so they sure are I think
there's a better chance that again going
back to vati like I think there's a
better chance of seeing something like
vati or the Minish or stuff like that
return because of the director hiramaru
fujibyashi who
directed The like he wrote this story
and the lore for diminished cap and the
Oracle games and so vati and diminish
are his creation uh
so
I I would expect him uh to be pretty
eager to put some of his own written
lore back into the Zelda Universe again
when you think about it though because I
a topic I always talk about on my
channel because I love it it's just like
life force you know light force from
Minish Cap so the fact that like he uh
yeah the fact that he like worked on
Skyward sort of Minish Cap and Skyward
Sword it was so huge on like the malice
and Gratitude Crystals and all that
stuff yeah pretty cool
oh good blood asks um
do you think that that uh wait oh that's
a different question do you reckon the
zonai or the Twilight
I think I think it's I think it is
possible yeah
like they're they're of a similar nature
you mean or like they are straight up
just I I think it's possible they are
the same but like it
Nintendo could also just be adding all
these uh dark tribes and they're
supposed to just be separate and never
mentioned like a theory that I still
really like is that you know the tribes
like the dark tribe The Interlopers the
ancient ones they're all like of this
similar tribe and when you have things
like the dark tribe and the Cursed
Mirror of the dark tribe and then you
compare that to like mirror of twilight
um it's all powerful forbidden magic and
stuff like that yeah yeah
but it's still like I cover I did it a
huge part of my second part of the the
whole zonai series was about that
possibility of The Interlopers uh being
someone related to The Zone eye and that
The Interlopers are related to the dark
tribe and you know ancient ones from
Majora's Mask but even then I preceded
that with saying that it's more on like
the speculation side because it's it's
outside of breath of the wild and we
really we really don't know they could
just be similar tribes that aren't
related it could very well be or maybe
we'll never know and we we have to just
piece that together and make it uh
something uh the art of mean asks do you
think the I symbols are related to vati
I I think so but
it could just be a little reference or
Easter egg
uh like the one on the shield it looks
too too much like
it's very similar yeah it's very very
similar like the way it looks up like uh
like almost uh Towards the Sky
it it's uh yeah it's it's very similar
so I do think it's probably at least a
reference to him
that's why I'm also like I really hope
he will be because can you imagine
seeing vati in 3D in a 3D Zelda game for
a change that would be amazing
uh because then you can have a similar
dynamic as you had with Zant and
um and Ganondorf and uh also to a lesser
extent Gary him and demise where you
have a villain and then a greater
villain who is even more dangerous
one character one character I loved that
I highly doubt would ever make a return
but I thought Yuga was very underrated
in a lake Between Worlds also his theme
slaps when you when you fight him for
the the last time before you guys yeah
but also like he's a case where he gets
ganon's power but it's not like a reveal
where oh Gannon was only using him and
ganon's the main villain
he like he fuses with Ganon and then he
it's still Yuga yeah yeah which I think
is really cool if anything he he takes
advantage of ganon's power as opposed to
the other way around yeah exactly and
you have some and then when you compare
that to like Twilight Princess where
Ganondorf pretty much uses Zant to you
know for his own uh evil deeds and then
also forces Adventures another one where
once you defeat vati there's like a
little cinematic and then you realize oh
the final fight's actually Gannon and
you realize he's a man antagonist oh
yeah
uh we have another question from Dwayne
uh
sorry for butchering your last name uh
Theory Ganondorf has a Triforce of power
and it's leaking uh through him like
like red malice he was sealed by the
Triforce of Courage green energy
from the hand and the ancient hero
and the Triforce of wisdom is the blue
Chic attack like the the ancient energy
I love that theory yeah I absolutely
love that I really I really hope that is
true because it's too coincidence it's
such a cool concept yeah yeah like all
these ancient forces are like
now manifesting in different ways in in
it yeah
I feel like that that um comparison is
definitely intentional it has to be
right it's it's it's the the three
colors that we know are important in
this universe
um if they reveal any new Tears like
Kingdom trailers do you think pre-orders
will go live on Nintendo eShop after the
direct I mean given what recently
happened with that that price that they
took down I wouldn't be surprised if
they now let people pre-order unlike
eShop
yeah
they will also probably have a
like a collection collector's edition or
something
yeah maybe yeah so like if they so if
they allowed pre-orders now that would
be the time they would likely announce
like a collector's edition or uh even a
switch themed system or a choose a
kingdom switch
you know yeah
which I would love just uh I have a
collector's box with all the necessary
stuff because they did that with uh
breath of the wild too right they they
had like those little marbles with the
uh Divine beasts on it and a map and
I didn't get it but it was like a
Champions Edition or something was the
no no that's the book that was the book
yeah I think that was a Korean the
champion that was creating a champion
I'm confused now I think one place I
think one place uh got a little like
Master Sword pedestal figure
or something I don't think I think it
was just like yeah it was something I
don't know yeah also uh thank you Dwayne
I forgot thank you for the donation
someone asked why I chose the name
Monster maze uh it's based on a video
game from the 80s it's considered to be
one of the first horror games ever
uh like ever made
it's called Monster mace 3D where you're
just walking around in a maze and
there's like a some sort of dinosaur
creature chasing you it's very primitive
but it's very funny
hey Dr Wiley boys crazy crazy
let's go
you're not streaming uh timer
you're 3D printing the master sword
right now oh that's cool I also recently
got into 3D printing it's it's magic
it's absolute Magic
William Martin says I'm so glad we might
actually get to see you again in this
time around even when the game first
came out I felt like coming again and
wasn't truly him yeah that's very true
yeah
something that I
had noticed it's funny I noticed this
prior to the sequel trailer but I said
like in a video Once
if you notice Calamity Gannon he never
the spectral form never left Hyrule
Castle so the question is why and then
the breath of all 2 trailer comes out
and then you see Ganon sealed somewhere
and it's like oh well that's probably
why he's probably under high will Castle
yeah
well that that it makes so much more
sense now and it almost feels like they
had a sequel planned all along but maybe
as DLC initially but you can feel that
the story in the end was not finished
and I think possibly had a I think it's
less they had a sequel planned and more
so they just had like major story ideas
for DLC yeah and then it ended up being
a sequel like you know
[Music]
um
because you cannot just reduce Ganon
back to a DLC appearance that's yeah
it's the first appearance of Ganondorf
as we know him
from Twilight Princess in what like
uh since when was Twilight Princess 2006
a very long time ago we haven't seen
Ganondorf in a very very long time
if you don't count remakes obviously
I think tears of the Kingdom will be
ganondorf's origin story well his origin
story is technically Ocarina of Time
but we will at least find out what he's
been up to all this time because he kind
of disappeared from history for a very
long time
uh let me turn down this I like imagine
imagine if Zelda just dies like oh well
imagine if zelders your style well I
could see it happening to be honest
obviously they're not going to do it
like in a gruesome way but I I could see
her dying
and
because maybe that's what the whole
oroboros thing is about
like if Zelda dies she's free from
highly as influence again so it's or
well her uh it's like
I don't know it's very hard to explain
like hylia and Zelda are kind of the
same thing same person but also not
because they did they they did start out
as two separate beings originally
yeah
what do you think ganondorf's voice will
be like
uh food I hope it's gonna be very feral
I hope he has a very feral voice
uh timer asks boys can I hop onto the
call with y'all more fun than watching
alone and I don't feel like streaming it
myself
uh do you wanna
why I mean if
I mean I'd be fine with it as long as we
don't scream over each other
yeah because uh I don't know how to I
don't know how to set up the Discord
group properly though yeah you have to
do an invite or something
invite to Sir oh no wait that's
something else invite to serve
uh
not sure add friend maybe
add friend to conversation
uh we are we are boomers actually you're
not a boomer at all you're you're
freaking Young no no I am Boomer let's
just say that
um
compared to some other people on this uh
like other Zelda fans you you are
considered a boomer Maybe
learning how to use Discord if you like
you're you're 25 right
yes yeah
yeah they could do something like that
man
I love the relationship between Link and
Zelda Spirit Tracks because it's just
like a pure like friend thing and Zelda
a Spirit Tracks is a case where she
actually you know helps I know that you
know in breath of the wild technically
it does isn't that she does nothing
because she holds back Gannon for a
hundred years but it's it was so cool to
kind of like Control Lincoln Zelda
um I am 35 Swamp Shack thank you very
much
25 is a boomer now it's a joke
no he thought I was 13 uh I was 39. it's
like no that's still a little little bit
well it's actually pretty close and
that's very scary
and add me to the call by going
to me on Discord
uh
I don't think so
can I just drag you in here no I cannot
um
you should do a video where you write a
new Zelda game that would be an
interesting thing for us to
I think you're I'm not able to it
doesn't let me
wait why does it say you need to be
friends with Nintendo black crisis to
start a group DM
we're not friends are we not friends are
you serious but it doesn't let me hold
on it doesn't let me send a friend
request I just hit add friend I'm not
sure if that oh we're friends now how we
how are we not friends all this time
we were officially not friends until now
guys
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh my gosh
create DM what do you mean
oh no wait that that just starts a
completely new call
Discord be confusing yo
I think you do have to like set up a new
group and then just join the call okay
here I think we just gotta hit start
voice call now and hopefully it works
okay so we I'll go I'll go ahead and
I'll go ahead and start this call
hello
surprise guest surprise
I swear to God if you're if your audio
quality is bad I'm kicking you straight
out of here again
what me
no so sometimes you have those people
joked sometimes you have those people
joining you and they're like they sound
like they're in a toilet or something
you're like okay well I mean I mean it
sounds fine right because yeah sometimes
my windows is like I have a genius idea
let's connect to the webcam microphone
instead and I'm like nope
I know there's an option to like change
the audio level of each person but I
don't know where it was oh yeah you can
uh I'm not very good at it you just
right you just right click on their uh
Avatar their little oh here we go
perfect all right just gonna set wileys
to zero percent
I was hoping you're gonna make that joke
[Music]
I mean you know we're both touch right
you can just bully us both at the same
time yeah
okay so we have 31 minutes left until
the direct starts
limbo
now we're gonna do some hardcore
theorizing
why did it pause my
my video I think uh uh my my theory is I
think Ganondorf will both be um like
Slimmer and shorter than link
Slimmer and shorter
yeah so he's not very threatening
well his corpse look pretty damn big
what so it's like so it's like that uh
sandwiches so it's like that scene from
the the Mario movie the first trailer
where it's like attack they're throwing
snowballs then you zoom out and they
just see back yeah basically like it
looks very menacing but in the end like
it just kind of gets up from his I don't
know stone slab like he's some sort of
Mayan mummy and then he's like a meter
tall or something like three foot four
foot you know foreign
it reminds me of the final phase of the
spider fight or the Goma fight in
Twilight Princess oh yeah we're just a
little hard and it's like the little
small and then funny the the music
completely changes
and then just running around yeah that
was a weird boss fight it was cool but
also that ending was so odd it's just an
eyeball with a spider's body I solved
the fight for me like all right this is
great
it helped the uh it was some something
they put in to help the arachnophobes
realize that it's just a teeny spider oh
you should have why I assume you've seen
like the older Twilight Princess trailer
where like links being chased around
that cave yeah in the cave yeah like
jeez man I looked on that like a little
bit ago because I'm like I wrote a
script about like the potential uh Twila
princess sequel they were gonna do and I
looked at that footage and was like man
Twilight Princess could have been even
more epic but it wasn't because they had
to cut down time and everything and I
think there was also
because a lot of people always say
um yeah the Wind Waker was smaller and
sunshine was rushed and blah blah blah
because they were kind of pushed which
is true but I think there was also a
problem with the discs because there
were smaller discs which were done
because of privacy you know piracy
reasons because the smaller discs you
couldn't really burn it on the normal CD
you know but those smaller ones didn't
hold as much data so they had to cut
back a lot on a lot of their games
because it just couldn't hold that much
data I think Resident Evil wasn't two
discs for that reason as well
hmm
it's a weird little technical gimmick
problem thing
yeah I do remember that that's uh so
they're they're paranoia for uh piracy
overruled having more capacity
basically yeah but that's just kind of
that's why the PlayStation two one
Nintendo thing
yeah that's why I was gonna say that
Nintendo does Nintendo stuff
yeah
and now they are using flash cards was
which is like the the easiest thing to
dump on a PC
I'm glad they're using flash cards so
they kind of like they saw the lights
because flash cards load incredibly fast
and are very portable and stuff oh yeah
they're just more expensive to use as
far as I remember like in the beginning
they talked about that a lot when the
switch was like new it was like oh yeah
but the cartridges are less profitable
because the flash things are more
expensive on the open market I was like
well rip but hey at least my loading
times are like 25 faster
tingles of the Kingdom yeah bring back I
do wonder what the I do wonder what
they're gonna do for like the next
generation of system
because the switch like it it's at the
point where it's like all right we need
new hardware oh yeah no it's yeah oh my
God like I could talk about that for
hours how bad it is oh yeah and Nintendo
is too proud to be like well we'll just
make the exact same thing but bigger and
uh like better uh performance because
they always have to do something new
I mean they did that with uh the Wii and
DS I mean
a tablet I mean the Wii was just bit it
was pretty much as from what I know it
was just pretty much the same as a
GameCube like specs it's super funny how
like Nintendo kind of I don't know what
it was but um Nintendo has these kind of
weird phases I've studied this and it is
fascinating and that is
um I would call it King of the Hill
syndrome like they become the king of
the industry like they did with the NES
and SNES then they become too cocky and
don't care that much and treat
um like businesses surrounding them that
make games for their consoles badly and
then they need to all of a sudden do a
pivot because they release an N64 and
GameCube that didn't do anywhere near as
well and they have new competitors and
then they decide to do a bit of a pivot
and with the weed they were kind of on
their last legs and a bit desperate so
they just took basically two GameCubes
glued them together and added a gimmick
to it and started treating outside
developers from like other Studios
better and that got them to a good
position and then they again became too
cocky and we had the exact same ride
with the Wii U they even wanted to
um make like Ubisoft already came to
them during the Wii U era to make the
Mario plus Rabbids uh game but Nintendo
shut it down after seeing like one
drawing of it and was like no we're not
doing this and now with the switch
they're like oh yes please come make
video game you know because it's like oh
yeah we need those other games because
otherwise we can't fill like the gaps so
people get bored with the console and
then they're like screw this and then
they leave well and you I believe you
also had a steam deck right yeah it's
great I love it yeah oh yeah exactly
exactly and I have and I got one and
it's like man this is this is so good
and I just shows like we really needed
like a proper switch Pro
uh yeah and I think also like the uh
competition is a good thing because it
it often forces Nintendo to adjust
realize change improve you know as
always happens in the world like
competition wise they don't necessarily
have to worry you know because like
obviously people are still gonna buy the
Nintendo consoles for the games I I
think most the competition is in like
that third party
because oh yeah yeah
because you know what I mean obviously
it's it's more expensive than the
Nintendo switch but
Nintendo could totally a lot well that's
the thing Nintendo could totally they
don't even have to like go as powerful
but they could definitely you know
upgrade the switch oh I think they can
easily reach steam deck levels you got
to remember the steam deck like the
hardware inside is based on
2019 AMD basically 2020 something like
that uh because it's our DNA uh just an
updated version of our DNA so maybe 2021
but
I think if they release let's say a new
console like at the end of this year or
maybe next year something like that they
can they can probably rival the steam
deck in terms of power I mean steam is
already making a steam deck too which I
found a bit weird because I was like oh
yeah they're gonna sell this thing for
like two to three years and then they
make a new one because it has faster
Cycles but is the stream laggy for
anyone else or is it just a storm
uh no it's not laggy for me I'm watching
it on the side so I can read chat and
look at all the funny little messages
and beautiful colors I don't know why so
it's just storm well and they
maybe then uh
never mind
no it looks fine bro
don't worry bro it's fine bro don't
worry about it no I think it's funny
that people always uh when when the
stream starts lagging for them they just
immediately assume like oh it's the
stream it's not my Internet it's just
and it just comes it just confuses the
the streamer where I have to check with
it in with everyone like is it is it
lagging is something wrong bro I
recently I recently had where I was
streaming and my software like the
software that was recording it looks
like the footage in the software that
was using to record it looked laggy as
hell so I was like oh God is it lagging
and then I looked at the stream itself
and asked other people and it's like no
it looks fine why does it look so laggy
the hardest the hardest one I think
aside from that is like audio check to
make sure everything sounds okay so that
because like that you you gotta like do
pre-recording stuff to test that out
because you know you ask and it's like
oh yeah audio sounds fine you listen
back to it and like it sounds really
quiet or you know I have people saying
oh yeah it's perfect other half being
like Oh it's way too quiet
it's it's fine storm I'm not blaming you
but I I always get nervous whenever it's
like the same thing when even if even
one person says like the audio is not go
down immediately I just started I start
finicking with controls like oh god oh
yeah oh yeah
fine and storm papa is very proud of you
little kiss no it's fine storm it's you
don't no need to apologize it's me it's
it's it's not you it's me
it's his own insecurities he's so much
iCloud Reign uh for the donation of
twenty dollars Zelda will narrate the
trailer and Ganondorf orlink will speak
by the end of the trailer I definitely
could see the the narration uh he please
don't ban me on Discord me unfairly a
year ago uh okay I will I will check
and see what up what was up with that
and I'll uh try to get back to you the
Nintendo Direct just went live by the
way so I have no more countdown
uh let me know what your Discord is sky
cloud rain just so I I can like
reference it when I talk to them it's
still like 22 minutes left before it
starts but
the timer yeah they do
yeah they do that bro I would love it if
just at the end of the trailer yeah when
they show off Ganondorf with link or
something it's it gives me like I would
love it if it gave me the exact same
Vibes as like that wolf character in the
new Puss in Boots movie like please
I haven't seen it yet so please don't
spoil it so good
no I'm not saying any extra details
I've seen it we are gonna we are gonna
watch it but uh we had the choice and um
my my fiance was like I'm not really
feeling an animated movie right now I'm
like all right well you know you're
please don't tell me you're you're a
gentleman so I I uh decided we will go
to uh to missing my family my family
went to see Avatar they're like oh do
you want to see that one oh my God no
I'm fine I was so underwhelmed by Avatar
too
are we going to spicy opinions it just
it just felt like a three-hour Tech demo
oh no here we go let's go boys and this
is and this is coming from someone who
was actually really really invested in
the first movie like I was one of the
few people who were like yeah I don't
care if it's derived from other stories
I I really liked it I really liked the
first movie a lot I saw it I've seen it
like at least six times and uh
uh but the second one
it just didn't do it felt like a rehash
of the first one like so many beats and
story beats and ideas were rehashed into
Avatar 2 so it just felt strange you
know it felt like I was watching the
exact same movie but Water World Edition
that's the only thing oh my sister
that's exactly like when my mom was
describing the plot I was thinking isn't
that like the exact same price it's even
the first movie but Water World Edition
it's it's even the same villain it's
just like the same villain is back even
though he's totally died at the end but
he downloaded himself to a new body it's
like what the bro I would love to have
that power though if that's possible
then nobody in this universe can
technically die because everybody can
just download their Consciousness to a
floppy disk or whatever bro when I turn
80 turn me into chat GPT version 500
please
that would be cool yeah anyway Let's uh
let's try this shift uh gears back to
Zelda because we have like 20 story we
have like no it's fine it's fine but we
have like 20 minutes left until the
direct and I might take a small bathroom
break before that happens or else I'm
gonna regret it
but uh
so timer what what do you what what are
you expecting to see uh from this yeah I
was are you I was going to ask you can
see since since you joined uh maybe you
could just uh if there's anything you
want to talk about quickly like do you
do you think uh do you think we're gonna
see more more so like a trailer akin to
the one we saw in 2017 for breath of the
wild like that big Epic trailer or do
you think they might mostly like focus
on gameplay where they like doing a
little demonstration thingy or something
well I mean we're really close to uh I I
have candy in my mouth if it sounds
weird
um
but we're really close to like the
game's launch and Nintendo has chosen to
go for their weird way of releasing a
new game like they did a similar thing
with Super Mario Galaxy 2 where it's
like nothing is happening blah boom
Super Mario Galaxy 2 here we go it's
gonna come in like no information
nothing like what what you know it's
like hey guess what what
do I expect them to
um go for a bit of a catch up you know
so I think there is actually a pretty
decent chance since we're so close to it
they've already told investors that it's
going to release at that date so it's
going to release especially after one
delay already
um so I kind of expect them to like show
a trailer and then move on to some bits
of gameplay or explain some specific
things in which
um tier City kingdom is different from
the original breath of the wild like
editions new power stuff like a little
bit of I think we're gonna there I think
there's a good chance we will get a
surprising amount of information first a
banger of a trailer or at the end but I
think at the beginning and then some
more details about the game itself you
know like the world Towers like a bit of
a tlbr I think if we get the next
trailer we get is going to be on the
scale of like the 2017 trailer yeah like
the story one you mean yeah kind of like
sort of because like it we have this
topic uh you know beginning this stream
where it's like oh how much story do you
think they're gonna show and I think it
would be structured the exact same as a
2017 how you make like you might have a
couple voice lines here and there and
maybe a few Story related cutscenes but
it's still going to be as vague as usual
I hope so because the 2017 trailer for
breath wild as awesome as it was it
contained like 90 of all the cutscenes
in the game everybody was like whoa this
this game is going to be huge what a big
giant story it's like No actually that's
pretty much all there is which game
breath of the wild the 2017 uh teaser or
sorry uh the 2017 trailer for
breathtwell the big one the story
trailer yeah pretty much like 90 of all
the big noteworthy cutscenes were in
there
oh yeah yeah since when is there a
limited why can I not tweet anymore what
is this
anyway well well timer tries to figure
out how the internet works I'm gonna
quickly uh I'm gonna quickly uh go to
the bathroom you you guys you guys keep
my audience uh entertained for it I'll
tell them about me being hacked uh no
but it's saying you
sending Tweets but talk about Zelda damn
it this is a Zelda stream nevermind uh
bro that's pretty cool they were tweets
about Zelda wow Zelda's pretty cool bro
I was tweeting that I was here all right
I'll be right back uh thanks guy for the
donation of two dollars I want vague
please be vague yes I absolutely agree
with you I want it to be vague
well yeah it would be better if it was
vague because I think like uh wasn't it
who said this is going to be dark bro
what I wanted to well that was that
reason well that was more so about just
the tone of the first trailer but but I
do I think a lot of us are expecting
even with that like proper context that
this will be darker and I hope it is so
it will be cool if it's like um you know
how Majora's Mask was in terms of story
and everything like vague and weird and
a lot of depth to it and a lot of angles
you could approach it I hope to go for a
similar type of thing this time and
don't tell us too much and then you just
play the game you're like oh my God this
hot what do you hope that the do you
hope that the
timeline will still remain like
ambiguous or do you want a conclusive
answer to it
because
on the other hand it's it's useful and
handy and gives a bit of structure but
on the other hand Nintendo doesn't think
about this kind of stuff at all so I
kind of want them to just ditch it and
come up with a new structure for how
this stuff works because it's kind of
like a good friend of mine birth keeper
Toby who does a lot of Pokemon content
said like was it was really into Zelda
theorizing as well for a very long time
and especially back in the day and still
is but he has a Pokemon Channel I mean
but
um he said he really liked the fact that
back in the day there was no timeline so
you could puzzle it you know you could
create your own timeline or how events
went and blah blah blah and I think
that's actually like
a better way of doing it like to keep it
a bit vague and no real structure and
just let people kind of figure it out
because to be honest what we as fans
come up with is a million times more
coherent and epic than what Nintendo has
made I don't know
yeah and even with the like I've always
considered breath of the wild to be like
a I guess a soft reboot of sorts of the
timeline
it is
[Music]
and I think it's the right direction to
be honest
it's better
yeah well I think it also might help
them
just with the future games
maybe in a way feel a bit less
restrictive
yeah it also like Nintendo just loves to
be creative that's the thing that
Nintendo cares about the most they love
being creative and I don't like to be
like tied down by certain either
conventions or story or stuff like that
you know so and then and when it comes
to the Super Mario games they're like
timeline what is a timeline stuff just
happens you know like it doesn't matter
bro I want to create like cool capture
hat mechanics leave me alone that's
basically just me they all of a sudden
they all of a sudden like release a
Mario game where they they have this new
villain and at the end he's like I will
return an incarnation of my hatred and
it's just like oh there's Bowser's
Origins sorry no no I wouldn't like that
just keep it a bit
fun little like I like how they added
with Super Mario Odyssey to brochure
which has all kinds a little bit of lore
tidbits you know but that's as far as
they should go in my opinion when it
comes to Super Mario at least but with
Zelda they can be more detailed but I
think some sort of overarching structure
and all kinds of lines in the sand with
limitations
just doesn't help and I mean it just
creates like
the problem is they create complex stuff
especially when it comes to storytelling
like time travel and then they're like
yeah yeah bro we have a timeline and
everything you know like trying to
maintain some sort of structure and
explain it all but then there are still
like 5 000 gaps which especially happens
with time travel stuff you know like
even time travel movies I mean Back to
the Future also had its flaws
um
so I think it's just better for them to
not worry too much about that and just I
don't know make cool games
and then we'll figure it out you know
what the timeline is how stuff works
blah blah blah and we just get some like
very rudimentary lines in the sand
but not like rigid structure such as a
timeline
because it's just fun and it's less of a
headache for them and all their attempts
so far and being like no bro we these
are the rules don't work you know it
just doesn't work whoa uh Skye thank you
for the Super Chat donations they're
gonna nuke the timeline like of course
they will I'm curious on the mechanics
absolutely I also I'm curious I think
I'll be a big focus of this next trailer
we get uh like will the gameplay be way
different from the breath of the wild I
hope so again yeah absolutely agree if
they're gonna go back to the same Hyrule
that obviously extends to Hyrule itself
the exploration uh if the gameplay is
the same we're all gonna be Pro going
into it yeah all those all those people
making those montages and stuff of like
crazy stuff in breath of the wild uh
Majora's master has made sorry Majora's
Mask is made of the year so obviously
they had to keep the same play style but
had plenty of time to build from the
ground up for this one yeah long story
short don't want glorified DLC yeah and
I think that would I can understand the
big the biggest worry because it started
off as DLC from what they said uh but
yeah that's absolutely true
foreign
well I mean
if the island if they have an
underground section section oh sorry I I
was actually muted sorry guys
basically I just said we have to get
like uh people have to be convinced now
in the next few months that this is
going to be more than just glorified DLC
but yeah go on uh give me your take guys
um
well I mean
DLC could like if you look through the
amount of ideas they had it's crazy and
then they already did DLC you know like
holy moly
um so I think like I think there will be
enough new stuff with like the with with
the sky island stuff and maybe
underground stuff most likely
underground stuff and
um then just kind of a revamped world
like below you know normal level
um
and I mean they can also add so many
weird enemies like have you seen what
kind of stuff they came up with bro it
looks more like Elden ring than
something Nintendo has ever made I would
love to see that as well I wanted to be
kind of messed up yeah
same here
am says I want the sequel to use those
Scrap Monster ideas give us something
truly terrifying yeah absolutely yeah
give me deadhead get that exactly and
and pre and another uh donation by uh
sky cloud mentioned uh like if I know
how to beat all the enemies where's the
challenge lionels were daunting at first
now they're a joke and that absolutely
is true but I'm sure like we've already
seen some weird creatures and stuff at
least there's that one from the 2021
trailer and then we have other things
that aren't necessarily enemies but you
have that robot which I have a feeling
probably is gonna play like a guardian
role kind of like you know other robots
in the series but there I don't think
it'll be an issue combat wise because
they're gonna they're gonna have tons of
new
battle related mechanics we've already
seen you know a couple things and like
having that like flamethrower Shield
add-on and I I would be shocked if they
didn't have like a ton of new enemies I
will be disappointed if they don't have
like that many new enemies it's like
really I mean they came up with like
flying saucers diminish a flamethrower
hand something that looked like it was
straight out of my nightmare or like a
jinji Ito manga or like berserk so I
mean we'll be like overloaded with all
kinds of cool stuff I think
I think at like around the five minute
Mark we should probably switch over to
the to the direct stream or at least
keep it open I will stop playing these
these teasers and trailers in the
background little promotional Clips I
downloaded as a vlp
actually actually uh Conrad from uh
Commonwealth realm he upskilled all the
trailers to 4K props to him for doing
that
yeah that's it oh oh bro I was over at
his stream like before I came to this
one and he he I saw that he got a
haircut and he apparently got it in
Japan and my God it looks so much better
he looks way better like this yeah for
sure oh my God I don't know what the
barber did over there but my boy Conrad
looking good yeah he's looking swag
and dark side 95 for the donation sorry
I'll be quick with this I just hope
cheers of Kingdom has as much as breath
of the wild to explore absolutely and I
still hope that like I I hope the three
main areas it's not just like Skylands
and the surface I want like underground
exploration areas kind of like what we
saw in the first trailer that would be
so amazing also zathan thank you for the
donation of 199 uh at work can't stay
have an amazing stream you guys well
thank you very much for the donation and
we will have an amazing stream and I
hope work goes well for you okay
continue
oh yeah well then now it's my turn the
art of mean thank you so much again uh
can we watch the previous teasers now
there's still time I just played the
previous teaser for you uh I don't know
if you saw that I switched uh oh boys
now it's my turn zayfam at work uh can't
see uh can't stay have an amazing stream
you guys oh thank you so much and uh
props to you for dropping by even though
and I have a good work day I hope you
can uh I hope you can manage Focus while
the direct presentation's going on
Eduardo uh Pacheco uh again sorry I hope
tears of the Kingdom will have better
side quests I feel like breath wild is
lacking in that aspect I absolutely
agree uh most of the side quests suck in
breath of the wild
it felt like it was very weird it it
almost felt like Fallout type of side
quests just get me this stuff there was
so little where it actually felt
substantial it was mostly that's that's
the cool thing with this like sequel
with three use sets just like all right
like a lot of side quests in Ocarina of
Time were also a bit
a bit you know there were a couple
at Mid and then when we got Majora's
Mask they upped the site game like
immensely you know so I kind of expect
that as well also little special message
from Wiley you all have been good boys
so I hope you get what you want from the
direct
something to drink real quick yeah yeah
do your thing this entire fireworks show
start I I also want to quickly mention
uh I'm all already got my document ready
with my uh partially made thumbnail you
know in case I need it with the trailer
analysis four minutes left four minutes
four minutes people
oh no
also shout out to Lighthouse horror
anyone who wants to find a good
Creepypasta narrator on YouTube he has
great work so uh by the way do you think
they're going to start out with uh tears
of the km Sims people are already
anticipating that it's probably gonna be
there uh or do you think they'll save it
for the end
I mean surely they'd want to like show
off some of the gameplay and stuff
I feel like if it was just the trailer
it would be at the end but if they have
like some like demo stuff to to also
cover maybe that'd be at the beginning
after the trailer I don't know
but also they would need another thing
to end off like a big 3D models well or
Metroid Prime four
what what came huh what well there is
some uh Credence to the idea that maybe
they will finally show it
because uh there were some updates to
the Metroid Prime I think they removed
like the pre-order options or something
I don't know what it was exactly but
Doug Bowser was very excited he was like
grab your bingo cards guys it was like
they could also make um they could also
make a separate direct for a Zelda
that's still something that's possible
but who knows yeah
oh thank you Jay get your bingo card set
well we don't have Bingo cards our Bingo
cards just says zonai
it's just so nice so we're gonna be
right either way
two minutes okay I'm gonna turn off the
music now
uh oh that's the wrong screen
yeah no more music
oh my gosh
I don't think I'm gonna be uh reacting
on camera this time guys because I I
it's 11 p.m almost here and I'm I I look
like
I just woke up he's just he's just upset
he doesn't look as fashionable as Conrad
yeah
actually uh if there's anyone going to
Pax this year my uh my Visa for the US
has been approved so I'm all set I've
booked my flight I'm going to be at Pax
so if there's going to be a Nintendo
booth
I will be able to play maybe a demo
of Tears of the Kingdom
I'm from the Netherlands
and we are good friends with our Pals in
the U.S so
they approved my uh my Visa request and
like it took them like two hours and
they were like yep you are not menacing
it should be starting any moment now
it's five yeah
give me a quick uh like if it starts on
your end I want to be sure that mine is
not accidentally paused or something I I
just know something can go wrong
let's get give me a quick uh little uh
yell if something happens on your end
but yeah one minute guys oh it's time
it is time
wait chapsi is here
where
oh Dwayne thank you so much
ah oh yep ah
okay you're good yes
they still have the
covet yeah
oh hey the covid-19 rules
all right here we go guys
it's happening
whoa this is looking wow it's in space
that's Pikmin
it's Zelda in space I told you we were
going to space Oh my God it was just
right oh my gosh we're getting Pikmin
news
finally
that's a pretty strong start
oh yeah oh look at all it's a Zona
look at all the look at all the cute
creatures we're gonna kill look at all
degree
that's right we're gonna kill them all
them up keep an eye out for uh zonai
swirls guys
yeah this is just uh this is just DLC
for Zelda don't get your hopes up
this is a strong start though
it might not be as like big of a series
as Mario
my sister will go nuts I love the I love
the free camera
kind of
yeah I like the angling more
I think it'll help really give off the
scale more
Zone I think
[Music]
foreign
like an actual proper new one it's a
proper that would have been Pikmin 3 for
the Wii I don't know when but it was a
very long time ago oh I'm gonna
I'm gonna buy this game now it has a
puppy it has a puppy look at him go
so cute
Huffman 2013 was the last one so like 10
years okay but can you pet the dog yeah
we have there's only one way to find out
go to that one Twitter account that all
the shares now
whoa this looks pretty Epic
this looks wild I played I played bits
of the first one a good chunk of the
second one all of the third one I'm
definitely gonna play this
I haven't touched the Pikmin game since
the first one
I'm uh I'm not really into Pikmin that
that much
personally
I do like RTS games a lot though
so it's a bit weird I don't know what is
this word timeline Pikmin stuff spooky I
saw I saw gratitude
here today is Nintendo Direct Mr
Takahashi is here he's in the building
yeah the dark like creatures will it
show us
please look forward to more information
in the future
let's see our first batch of Nintendo
switch headlines here we go
and now the rest of this direct will be
breakfast
I might I might I might be a bit behind
by the way the Xenoblade Chronicles
I think we're about the same but you can
refresh I accidentally my Mouse has a
hotkey on it I've never switched or if I
accidentally press it it like goes back
a page uh you can just refresh
itself a little bit
Xenoblade Xenoblade stuff
okay it might be a bit harder to hear us
I'm gonna have the direct feedback what
is it a timer
you might have to turn up the audio of
the direct a little bit I see people in
chat about it
even a couple more DB and coming in
volume four later this year
I've turned it up a little bit
is it better like this yeah okay he's a
heartless
yeah better
what the heck was that
now now I lost my train of thought
volume
I thought I saw Elvis
what like Elvis Presley or no
kids
owl this
you would
you are clearly not into Xenoblade no no
no no grab your joy-con controllers
to match the target s during a song well
I am excited for this
selfish
and dance
but the unexpected might happen so stay
it's one of those weird Wii games
why not dance with a friend to predict
your compatibility and love checker
wait these monkeys are from Sonic racing
style too I have no idea compete online
like what's your favorite Sonic
character the monkeys
play songs nft Dance
it is where's my metamask wallet when
Samba de Amigo Central Jimmy's onto
Nintendo switch Jimmy's it's Jimmy's
Hunter Nintendo switch
[Music]
for fashion
Fashions
new place to Glam it up and express
yourself well I thought this was just
gonna be some weird dress-up game
Sonic Frontier map Zelda is looking
different guys forget I forget forget
yours is the kingdom this is what I'm
interested in bro I love the other
analysis video of just this
for three days before
um the first of April April fools you
know so you could make a video
sometimes other people are wearing by
liking them
yeah this kind of world why are these
people on top of skyscrapers
I don't know it's the floating islands
bro yeah it's the floating island
these are all zonai
the zonai were very fashionable actually
nobody knew that then get styling when
fashion dreamer debuts it kind of weird
like incredibly pale though
like almost as if they're a zombie well
they've been living on the ground all
this time
oh that's a good argument though
back in
this looks awesome
oh I love this art style so much
bro this game is great
I've played all the castlevanias except
the 3D ones
so
okay
I love this sort of art style I love
this music
March 6th yeah there's something magical
about it it's timeless
yeah it is I mean diminished Capital
still looks amazing as well Adventure
set within the truck that game is like
five billion years old cover dangerous
funny how an art style that started from
graphical limitations became such a
staple you're
really nobody in their right mind would
make a video game that looks like early
N64 Graphics nowadays for consoles on
Nintendo no because that just looks
weird yeah
yeah why do people not do that that's a
good question wait if people see that
nowadays it's just like what is this uh
like failed Indie debt to recommending
murder mystery Ghost Trick although have
you seen the tears of the Kingdom uh
like the first breath of the wild two
trailer in N64 Graphics yeah I've seen
that one I've also seen the support
it's pretty funny
Nintendo switch this summer
Thriller
what is this
[Music]
getting away
oh my God
daycare police
it's just like a decaffeinated version
of police work or something
oh I hate this run cycle
as an animator I hate it
it's it's too floaty so many so many
Walk and Run cycles are too floaty
there's no weight behind it
that's how I feel with a lot of the
sword or not the sword shield by scarlet
and violet animations yeah it's very
floaty it's also uh
certain design and like other choices
they have made that were mediocre I also
really hated it in the uh Ocarina of
Time 3D and Majora's Mask 3D the the Run
Cycle doesn't look right
it feels like he's ice skating
um
like like there's not enough bounce to
it
yeah
yeah like the original actually felt
weighty
you kind of has the feeling that it's
like
from between him
yeah yeah yeah exactly that once upon
like it doesn't
a lot of anime uh today witch named
cereza
oh wait this is not really power to
rescue yeah that's true he Ventures deep
into the Avalon the Japanese Market
especially loves that and now the
Western Market also loves it to be fair
uh breath of the wild also is kind of
anime
well but it has the typical big anime
eyes and stuff same time oh yeah
like compared to Skyward Sword
which is also cell shaded they'll need
to
need to have bigger eyes magically
I think let me look it up let me look it
up
man or stop an aggressive one to focus
on another
strategically use each character's
ability to win battles this looks pretty
flashy uh though to be fair
the animation looks really good strength
as they continue their Journey knee by
obtaining more power this tickles my
animation uh
animation brain yeah
actually disappointed eyes and skyward
Swords were a little bit bigger I knew
it
wow
it's not that big of a difference
between the two either switches it looks
like the skyward Swords ones are a
slightly bigger in the shop and a bit
more stylized what was that how was that
well it was pretty mid
aside from Pikmin
look at this what is this well I won't
advance forward now that somebody
mentions it oh Pikmin
more Pikmin
[Laughter]
we bring the Pikmin up day to Splatoon
wow
I still think it's so silly I still need
to play Splatoon 3 sometime
I I just
I cannot bring myself to
investing time into it
why not
is it like it like not really your cup
of tea or
well it's just I don't know
I'm more into single player stuff and I
I think Splatoon is just too much uh
like a lot of the fun depends on being
online
expansion
this paid DLC I mean it has some single
players though I haven't played an
online game like since Smash Brothers
ultimately
make them splatastic place from the
original Splatoon I'm a cheeky
connoisseur in the Minecraft yes
well if I don't if I don't count like uh
code streaming with my friend just
playing Minecraft that I guess that
counts too
that counts as multiplayer
yeah
I ship Dawn in NBC
well either of you has to move to the
other side of the world then for that to
happen and I would have to have a firm
talk with my fiancee
[Music]
if we're talking Nintendo multiplayer
games
the only thing I've really play is Mario
Kart yeah
DLC launches I haven't played Mario Kart
online in so long same here
it just frustrates me because it's like
I I I think I'm okay at the game we're
good because I play with friends and
whatnot and time trial I do pretty okay
and then I play online with other people
and then it's just hell hell absolute
hell kill issue bro
my God you're just like my twist chat
bro watch my whole complete one hour
over one hour my okay Deluxe guide
instant Pro not that freaking video so
long
I could do it and become a Mario Kart oh
this is still Splatoon stuff I mean in
all seriousness there are a lot of very
useful tips
all right time to watch that and best
even more
platoon 3 expansion past side order what
does that mean
this looks like very abstract and odd
and I like that
yeah Color Splash you gotta you gotta
restore all the color to the town
oh my God
[Laughter]
yes they actually listened to make sure
not everything ties back to Mario
Sunshine
that's that's the one sequence that
never is gonna happen that I'd like to
see happen yeah
I love Sunshine tickets hated too much
many people have played well I mean
Nintendo did kind of cut Corners a
little bit oh yeah that's just uh Dr
Wily's whole world is Majora's Mask and
Mario Sunshine with the upcoming bro
everything I see if I see two pairs of
eyes
even though I'm talking to my girlfriend
give me some more
get some
let's see some more
Adventure awaits Mickey and friends on
illusion yes
Donald Duck
and Goofy wait who I I don't know is
this like uh the Kingdom Hearts for
switch and save them Furious island of
Mana wait aren't there Kingdom Hearts
games will switch runs I think only
versions Cloud versions
talk to HMK that's the only way to get
around all the licensing chill
abilities match new places and finds I
mean clouds can run well but it can yeah
ground pound barriers to open new space
but a lot of people's setups are not
ready for it yet
it also depends on the game
HMK recently got fiber
fiber so is speed it's like a much
faster internet I
thought you were talking about the
disease fiber
we're all over the place but this one
thank you
yeah
I think HMK tweeted like at least seven
or eight times about it in a row I would
I would because that speed though oh boy
yeah that speed's looking good bro
they're putting down
so jealous
well we already had like 300 MB
40 like 300 bit MB download already
DLC expansion class already it just
released it just came out well to be
fair with uh breath while they also
announced the first DLC pack like in
June
I've recently finally I finally uh
started playing this week I haven't gone
very far but yeah I saw it on Twitter
that you started this year
papaya
oh three includes uh Fire Fire Emblem is
so not my thing
Veronica
[Music]
and it was like you know
I tried it and I was like yes
well you're into that that good old
waifu stuff right
oh no what a shot
because I had never tried a uh turn like
turn-based but you know that tactical uh
just like a like a
safe term-based things yeah yeah so yeah
so I'd always wanted to try it and it
was really fun
Strokes for different folks later
I like what they did with uh what was it
Final Fantasy VII
because that was like active but with
some selection in between Destiny it's
it's very it's very overwhelming uh when
you try to play a game like Fire Emblem
because like in three houses they also
add extra mechanics and it's just so
much stuff I feel like I need to learn
and even after being a second time
recently with a different route I'm like
Adventure I feel like I only know like
10 of the combat how it works
I feel like this direct is gonna have a
very strong finale because everything so
far has been pretty pretty mid yeah
so I think it's gonna have a a banger of
a finale we are official
yeah it has to be like something huge at
the end not and I'm not just talking
Zelda because we're already expecting
each other
there has to be that one more thing at
the end
against your impact for the switch
finally
we already knew this it's like it's like
oh gesture impact's big right that works
it's like no no no
this is what I mean with Nintendo it
gets to the biggest Heights and becomes
the king and then becomes lazy this is
what I mean you take my prophecy
I don't think I'm too hostile so I love
this right
I don't think I'm being too harsh on the
direct I'm just saying it's mid like no
no I mean like there are always people
who say you're riding are harsh enough
for two parts so I wouldn't worry too
much about it it's like that there has
been plenty of stuff that's like really
uh for some other people this might be
like huge like uh the Splatoon people
the Pikmin people but you know those
just happen to be if I emblem those just
happen to be franchises I personally
don't care much about but yeah that's
kind of the problem I've had with
Nintendo the last two years or something
because I don't care about Pokemon to be
honest I don't care about the Fire
Emblem you know so I'm just patiently
waiting for like Zelda and Mario and not
getting anything
it will be there
I hope so I want Super Mario Odyssey too
bro metric is more metric Prime core
please if we don't get any uh Zelda's
direct I'm just gonna post a tweet
that's just dot dot dot that's awesome I
will I will join you on that one video
like analyzing okay all three of us if
there's no Zelda tears of the Kingdom
news we just at the same time tweet.com
Oh no you're you're good uh uh Giacomo
or
Jack Como
I I guess I I guess I could have worded
it a little bit differently it's not
necessarily a mid presentation but it's
mid for me
nothing exciting for you so far yeah in
fact it's pretty easy
if this would be it this would not be my
direct
no this wouldn't be our day
but we still we still have plenty of
time left Nemo says Mario Kart 8 DLC
please I mean this thought I wouldn't be
surprised if they teased the next wave
all we need is a three minute tree a
trailer for uh tears of the Kingdom bro
online first three entry in Odyssey
games is coming to Nintendo switch
remastered next anime please well at
least it's not a farming simulator
anymore yeah that's true we haven't seen
one we haven't seen a single Farming
Simulator yet like like
for the very last announcement it's just
all starving simulators what if what if
the tears of the Kingdom trailer but
it's like farming fast
I would love it it would be cool but it
would be a funny joke yeah
the new Zelda games like a Zelda game
but it has kind of like skills a stardew
valley
I would love it that that would be cool
yeah I love Harvest Moon and stardew
Valley so I'm sold you know I don't have
time for those types of games but I'm
sure my fiance would like it advantage
of new difficulties bro it's so much fun
to have your own little farm and then
you have the power when you call it
great
names or names that are only
understandable to aliens sure
finally it's here this is what people
were asking for oh yeah
it's only a couple of months away
yeah I think so
because there's a war yeah because it
happened around the same time
I'm happy for the uh that it finally did
show up
because it was a bit uncertain
of April 21 so it is launching before
The Legend of Zelda long long simulator
[Music]
whoa this is kind of Kirby is getting
some love this year guys whoa backstory
last year there is actually a lot of
Lori and Kirby games apparently oh yeah
I've seen videos where it's like Lord
Kirby and it's like one hour or
something that's like oh that's crazy
bro
but this is just a remake of Return to
Dreamland right yeah but it's adding a
little extra story with uh with one of
the characters here um to regain
magalore's Powers I like Kirby but I
think it's difficult enemies well that's
not for the those types of people I
guess it can be restored although the
the ones on Game Boy were sometimes
quite challenging I loved Mouse
you know which uh Kirby game was hard
Kirby's uh Kirby's ghost trap
yeah it's a puzzle game
the Kirby based puzzle game it's like
kind of like a Dr Mario oh my god oh wow
I've never seen that in my life look it
up Kirby's ghost trap it was it was
pretty damn difficult it's one of those
like uh Tetris type things yeah yeah
but it looks more like jelly beans I
don't remember if it was on N64 or
GameCube but I think it was probably
wait I said yes the original was SNES oh
yes SNS because my mom used to play that
one after today
[Laughter]
select stages
Kirby's Return to Dreamland Deluxe
Launches on the Nintendo switch system
as soon as I see how Numa I'm gonna
scream available
Dreamland
Nintendo switch online please take a
look at this
it's funny because like I need like one
second I'm like one second behind uh
monster maze so I just gotta hear his
his reaction yeah
boy games this game is so cool 3D Mario
let's go play these games but why is it
not white screen what is this Nintendo
emulators long ago oh Tetris everything
I wanted
well I'm pretty happy about like Super
Mario Land 2. yeah me too me too high
score it's a very good game
six golden coins
the castle that Wario still but I'm
disappointed by the fact that it's not
widescreen's Awakening DS oh this is uh
only Link's Awakening to escape
so now if they follow this by saying oh
yeah GameCube virtual console that would
be great yeah that's what I really want
that's what everyone wants yeah
women watch Gallery three play an
assortment of Game and Watch titles
wow um Minish Cap is Game Boy Advance so
I'm not sure if that's going to be
Shadow Island yeah so far it's only Game
Boy and Game Boy Color it would be cool
you can play A Link to the Past if we
don't see if we don't see the Oracle
games that could mean that they are
working on a uh remake
Dreamland is also fun A classic I played
a lot of game boy back in the day you
can use the long boy
Game Boy probably my favorite console
for my YouTube filters oh that's cool
the two players can play compatible
games
wow it's like three consoles in one it's
like all the games I've already played
long long time ago whoa already
the Oracle games are there
wait
oh
[Music]
that's good that's expansion pack okay
yes okay that's good that's that's
pretty good still well it looks like I'm
gonna go
I guess that I guess that means no
remakes for those games
that's good that's a massive wrath oh
yeah oh my God they're also like a
million 2D Super Mario games on that
band yeah
I hope they have like the Pokemon one
Pokemon
they're so expensive to get 10 minutes
left guys
10 minutes left Superstar Saga oh this
is such a good game I love it I've never
played Star Saga oh you should it's so
good
I could never I could never beat it I
got close to being it but I struggled on
uh one of the later fights I struggled
on the final boss and up to four players
oh you can also play online with friends
oh that's great let's go boys let's hope
it's better than Mario Kart 64 online
oh was that horrible
uh yeah
boy titles with the Nintendo Golden Sun
membership
or play both oh this is great Game Boy
Advance titles with the Nintendo switch
online yeah expansion pass yeah of
course I don't I don't like that they
have that extra one that they made why
is he still playing Mario
all right everybody
he was playing tears of the Kingdom on
it
oh it's like available right like later
today already that's pretty cool
all right Nintendo switch online if you
haven't played banished yeah if you can
actually buy that annoying expansion
pass
like play Minish Cap what is happening
oh it's just one though it's not the
trilogy unless it's gonna be like oh and
two and three are also coming to the
well okay but that was already kind of
hinted at that it was just going to be
the first prime
it's cool to see it back though I might
get down now I can finally uh we the
articles are constantly saying oh rumors
of the trilogy they can finally stop
yeah
I can finally stop after this bro it's
just stop all those foreign articles bro
we promised internet direct next week
next week nice
this looks pretty damn nice I still
haven't played the original does not
look as good as you remember it looking
[Music]
does that mean we're going to see metric
Prime 4 now
the first Metroid that'd be a great way
to follow up cheers for the kingdom is
canceled
has been yeah you're only getting
Metroid Prime explore Talon 4 from the
perspective of Samus I I could see how
expensive
I actually I I could see like to be fair
I could see a numa showing up at the end
and being like hey guys we're gonna have
a special direct specifically
potentially Kingdom so we're not going
to show anything now
I would not be disappointed because a
whole direct like specifically for Zelda
I can wait another few weeks
yeah but I have expectations and they
have not been met
[Laughter]
I'm not saying that's gonna happen but
I'm just keeping the possibility in the
back of my mind
no this is copia while separately
changing yeah that's true
side of this game
this game it's gonna be safe
what should be 60. it's going to be
Dolphin Emulator can do a better job
Launches on Nintendo
whoa that's quick
wow whoa whoa whoa that's very quick
that is ridiculously quick someone got a
chance
come on enough with the enough with the
anime stuff organization
seen a trend Don and she nigami the
spirit haunting him oh and how long do
we have left before our face this should
have been this should have been saved
for like with the other anime stuff
[Music]
alongside Master detectives this is not
like a f like you cannot put this after
Metroid because nobody's gonna care
about it even less now during
investigations
mimic body types and voices
bang your rompa I think detect
heartbeats and whistles well the good
news is guys uh if we're gonna get it
like a three minute trailer for uh tears
of the Kingdom uh it's still possible we
still have five minutes left yeah at
this point it would just be a trailer so
use them too yeah it might be yeah I
don't expect any Gameplay at this point
I expected because the release so I
think they will have like a treehouse
type of presentation later
inconsistencies and uncover the truth
because they they did do that with E3 as
well they had like additional uh
gameplay presentations in the days after
yeah but E3 is a total it's its own
thing when it comes to how directs work
with tree houses I'm curious how they're
going to do that this year's release a
dying contest coming to Nintendo switch
if not dead already peaceful error and
stabbing Islands above Earth the Empire
I mean some people still holds Hollow
sir it's dwelling within the
protagonists
imagine it's Pikmin four Pikmin four was
at the beginning bro
four minutes
where's silk song where's Zelda all
right everybody
that lies all right chat I gotta hand
that copium over here give me a swig of
the bottle
like for us
and I put a put Link in my thumbnail
which I normally never do but I was so
confident this time
never be confident with Nintendo bro I
mean there's still time there's still
time it says roughly 40 minutes which
could also be mean
43 minutes all three programs roughly 40
minutes
oh come on
bro just is this the farming
farm games
nah it looks like uh it looks like an
ammo Crossing art style
I really don't want to be uh like uh
I really don't want to be that guy but
geez so some of some of this stuff could
have been saved for a different
presentation like an indie showcase
I don't know okay it's okay there's
still time guys we've got the first
Farming Simulator guys oh this oh
this is a farming simulator I told you
everybody I told you they're saving all
the farming Sims for the for the end
that's the big finale
really look like mobile games I think
maybe they could be cross platform too
yeah this is totally like animal
crossings
yeah
all right we have two minutes left like
we could squeeze it no it says roughly
40 minutes so it could be 43 minutes
okay oh yes wait oh
I love how I have an indicator called
yeah exactly yeah both of us have like
Dawn here oh Professor Leighton though
oh that's pretty cool though they're
bringing back Professor hey that's that
is pretty good yeah that's pretty good
that is very cool my sister loves this
and I like these games as well it's
pretty good yeah yeah
um
oh my gosh that's gorgeous should I be
excited because I I don't know it's
Yoshi's Island course it's the new
course
that's beautiful
it looks really cool
characters
that is not con that was not planned
right
of course past DLC for the market guys
there could be new characters now that's
a possibility the door has been opened
okay okay
that's totally good that's a massive W
yeah
it can also be purchased I like to boost
their course pass so far a lot oh yeah
it is very good oh Blanc I'm gonna go
I'm gonna get Blanc for sure okay here's
the Montage there's gonna be one more
announcement after this yeah that's how
it always works that's always how it
works I'm also excited for that new
Minecraft game Minecraft Legends not
yeah
there's like RTS this game is going to
be so much fun to play with my fiance
Blanc
that's so cool
a Nintendo black prices was officially
hypnotized playing Nintendo
sure no shelter but
I think so far my favorite surprise is I
don't think it's gonna be something else
everyone everyone will be our last
segment segment
oh oh that's it yes yep there we go
yes that yeah oh there's a close-up of
that Tower with a swirl yeah here we go
oh that's the new enemies whoa those
birds oh crap they look like a light one
of the lights by the Rito is that Rita
no that's chicken tap oh
Towers here we go
look at these eerie
is that dragon on the right
oh my God this is a dark timeline
oh my God
it's so cool holy crap
this is like a dark timeline how did it
actually happened this music huh
this is gonna be some epic oh my gosh
hey the horny vocabulins
whoa what's this this is crazy
oh my God this looks what what is
this music
whoa whoa what Golem stuck get it or
whoa the time we go
holy
[Music]
ah yes we're in boys
what the hell this I love this like dark
timeline five those those are the rails
don't flooded see the hand the hands
what the hell
[Music]
why can't you build cars we feasting
tonight
bro this is like another paycheck and a
half bro
oh there's much more to analyze in this
one oh holy oh please lend him your
power oh so oh he jumps after Zelda oh
he jumps after her
so he basically got his hand burned and
the master sword messed up and then he
jumps after her because the malice is
coming Zelda of the Kingdom the latest
also the beginning will be like some
sort of a great downfall
what is it what else do you have to say
a collector's edition
a new amiibo figure of link from this
game yes
I might get that
yeah amiibo yeah
oh my gosh it's almost the exact statue
the big one bro boys we finally got
something to eat yes
I feel like that one song from like
Eminem where he talks about like sitting
at the table and eating all right guys
oh that was pretty damn cool that was
such a good trailer that was a really
good trailer yeah all right
I gained the Twitter issue as well I
can't post on Twitter
hey I told
Twitter as as breath or uh tears of the
Kingdom has broken Twitter no no it just
didn't no it just didn't work Elon Musk
all right now I really need to pee and
then I'm gonna talk with you boys about
this Feast yeah but and we are over my
daily limit for sending Tweets we are
probably gonna get to work also soon on
some analysis stuff
that's actually insane that is that was
such a good yeah let's see if they
already posted it
yeah I gotta get that YouTube downloader
oh yeah get the YouTube downloader out
boys get the YouTube downloader ready
wait I I forgot what I use for
downloading uh because I switched
recently
one sec boys I'm gonna go to the toilet
it's not that music was that music was
insane that music was so good
and ganondorf's voice probably that was
ganondorf's voice for sure I'm expecting
a 40 minute analysis video next in the
next half out from uh no it's gonna be
more than 40 minutes bro
there's more than 40 minutes worth but
yeah I will
yeah get outer stuff I yeah
we're just gonna have to analyze as as
yeah art of mean
I'm not gonna do like a full analysis
here on stream but uh I will start just
going through it myself and uh getting
my thoughts together I'm gonna deal with
something a little bit different I'm
gonna do like uh
instead of like a whole edited video I'm
I'm horrible at recording a voiceover
quickly
so I'm just gonna do like a semi life
just pre-recorded uh like frame by frame
thing where I just yeah I'm still not
sure what I'll do I'll just kind of look
at the trailer and see where that goes
it's not there yet I cannot download
cannot download
okay well um I think I'm gonna end my
stream now uh yeah so same same here
yeah I hope you go for watching uh
expect I probably will have a video out
maybe
I don't know if I'll be able to get one
out uh today given how it it's gonna
take a while to make a video but
probably expect one tomorrow
I'm going blind everybody
we're gonna
yeah we're gonna end the stream thank
you thank you all so much for uh for
showing up uh we we are both going to be
working on our analysis and just going
through the whole thing
because all right time to go Goblin mode
boys yeah Goblin mode my voice is
already almost gone so that's gonna be a
fun fun recording better Harvest one
voice over from it now that you can yeah
well anyway thank you all so much for uh
for for joining thank you so much for
all the donations uh for the company
uh we got what we wanted I guess uh that
at least the the Zelda boys and girls
did
hell yeah
the rest of the direct I would say was
but for me at least but for the Pikmin
people and Splatoon people Fire Emblem
people obviously they they got
some good stuff too yeah I mean it could
certainly be worse Xenoblade DLC it it
pretty much got everything oh there it
is whoa like they posted it three times
with different languages and I think I
don't know why they did it I gotta get
the Japanese version because then you
don't have any PG-13 stuff and you might
when you get that do you mind sending it
to me
yeah same here
uh okay so yeah thank you for watching
you can just go to Nintendo Japan
Channel they should have it up there too
Sean says Celtic has half a script
already done
yeah what is this no no no no nice guy
horse
joke but like I don't know how he gets
this stuff out like five hours later
it's like fully out I'm like oh fully
edited thank you but yeah it's at home
and
then he doesn't make too much content so
he doesn't really have like anything
specific in the pipeline and
well there's there's three three
trailers uh uh they posted three of them
one of them is two seconds longer than
the other two is there some secret there
to be found there
let us see thank you thank you for
watching and um I will see you guys in
the next video which might be I love you
all bye yeah kisses thank you all uh so
much uh everyone and uh we will see you
uh I will see you in my upcoming video
all right see ya all right bye bye